The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's
situate ourselves where we are.
So we're starting to really
make a lot of progress
here, moving in the V model.
Today's topic is session
five: tradespace exploration,
concept selection, and PDR--
preliminary design review.
So there's a lot to
talk about, and I'm
going to go relatively
quickly through this.
So, first I want to talk
about decision analysis.
Fundamentally, when
you come up for PDR,
you have to make a big decision
which is, what concept are you
going for?
What is your system
architecture?
That's a big decision.
You don't have all
the details yet.
The design is not
fully done, but you've
chosen your key architecture.
That's a big
decision, and there's
a whole branch of research
and science called
decision analysis.
So I want to tell
you about that.
Talk about some of the issues
in concept selection, and then
give you some tools
for doing that
in a kind of organized way.
There's a couple of--
what I would say, simple methods
Pugh matrix and multi-attribute
utility--
that are relatively, I
think, straightforward.
And then there's a bit more
advanced concept called
non-dominance--
Pareto frontiers, getting into
multi-objective optimization.
And so, at a minimum, when
you choose your concept,
you want to choose a
non-dominated concept.
And I'll explain
what that means.
And then we'll close with
discussing what is a PDR?
What do you do with the PDR?
What's the purpose of it?
So, here is another way to
explain essentially the flow
of things as we come up to PDR.
So the way you can
think of it as, you
start with a need, right?
And your requirements.
That's-- we've talked
about that before.
And then you have
this creative phase,
which we talked about
last time, right?
You come up with a lot of
ideas, a lot of concepts,
and the funnel that you
see here is going up.
So each of these shapes here--
the circle, the triangle--
they're meant to represent
fundamentally different
concepts, different
architecture,
different way of satisfying
the requirements.
And so there's a lot of
different things you can do,
and the funnel opens up.
This is sort of the size
of options or alternatives
you're considering.
And then you have
to filter this down.
In the end, you can only
build one system, right?
You have to choose
one architecture.
And this filtering down
happens typically in two steps.
One is what we call
concept screening, which
is more qualitative.
And then the actual
concept selection
is more quantitative, based
on models, based on data,
based on metrics.
And then you arrive at PDR.
So in this sort of
simplified view,
we've chosen the
square as our concept.
And we've made that
decision by looking
at these different metrics.
So you can see that
on this graphic here,
we have metric one, metric two--
you can see the triangle
is dominated, right?
The triangle doesn't
do as well if we
want to maximize
metric one and two,
so it wouldn't make sense
to choose the triangle.
But the circle and the square--
circle does better on
metric two, but less well
on metric one.
The square does better on
metric one, not quite as well--
and they crossover
at some point.
So, whatever-- how you weigh
this in decision making,
the decision is made.
We're going to go
for the square.
That's our concept.
And then you move to the
actual system design, post-PDR,
which is all the details.
So we're expanding the box
now, the square, and designing
all the details within--
the structure, the avionics,
the software, the controls.
And that's design
modeling and optimization.
And so here I'm showing you
metric three, which is maybe
another metric, and then
design variable x1, which
is some pretty detailed
decision that you
make within that
concept, and you're
looking for the optimal, in this
case, minimizing metric three.
It's this point here.
And then that gives
you your-- and I
put this deliberately in
quotes-- optimal design.
That's what you show at the CDR,
and the critical design review,
and that's what
you go and build.
So that's roughly the
flow of decision making.
Any question about that?
That general flow?
So what we'll talk about
today is essentially
this portion here,
concept screening
and concept selection.
So, since you make a decision,
what is decision analysis?
So decision
analysis, in general,
is methods and tools
for ranking and choosing
among competing alternatives
or courses of action.
And I just want to make--
the word alternative.
A lot of people use the
word option and alternative
sort of as synonyms.
They're not.
OK?
Options and alternatives
are not the same thing.
An alternative means if I choose
A, I can't choose B and C.
But the fact that you've
chosen A, or the square,
or whatever your concept is,
means that you cannot choose
the other ones.
An option means, well
given that I've chosen A,
I could also add something
on top of A, right?
It's kind of like if you
were buying a new car,
are you going to get the
winter package or not?
That's an option, but you've
chosen a particular vehicle.
So, that's important.
So alternatives are mutually
exclusive choices or courses
of action.
So you need the
alternatives, those
are the components-- four
components of a decision.
You need criteria, which means
how are you going to evaluate
and compare the alternatives?
Then you need value judgments.
You now apply the criteria
to the alternatives
to compare them,
and then finally you
need a decision
maker, which is either
an individual or a
group with preferences
to then make the choice.
Those are the four ingredients
of decision analysis.
And if we show this somewhat
graphically-- so here's
our alternatives.
We can do A, B, or C.
The criteria in this case
are cost, performance, and risk.
Then we basically evaluate,
in this case, option
or alternative A, I should
say, for cost, for performance,
for risk.
And this gives us
some score or number,
and then we need
to figure out a way
to combine this to
rank the alternatives.
And when it comes
to ranking, there's
a distinction between what's
known as an ordinal scale
and a cardinal scale.
So in an ordinal ranking all
you really care about and do
is say, what's the best
choice, the second best choice,
and the third choice.
You ordered the alternative.
But you don't know in an ordinal
ranking or ordinal scale,
whether one and two
are really close,
and then there's a big
gap between two and three.
You don't know that, and
you don't really care.
All you want is the rank order.
When you put things
on a cardinal scale--
so this is a continuous line--
you actually get, in a
sense, both the order
but you also see how close
the alternatives are.
So that's a cardinal scale as
opposed to an ordinal scale.
OK?
So-- yes?
Please.
AUDIENCE: How do you get a
discrete value for something
like risk or
something like that?
And especially in
an ordinal scale,
if you have two things that
are really close to each other,
but the risk is kind of a
blurry region, how do you--
PROFESSOR: So then they
would be equivalent in terms
of that criterion.
And you can actually
have ties, right?
You can have alternatives
that are tied.
And I'll talk
about-- this is one
of the issues in
concept selection
is, how do you do tie breaking?
Good question.
Any questions at EPFL?
I know this is very abstract.
But fundamentally,
that's what we do.
Any questions over there?
Is it clear?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
So let's keep moving.
So what are the issues?
I think that's-- so
multiple criteria,
how do you deal with them?
We usually have multiple
criteria and how do we--
and eventually, when you
make a decision, when
you pick a concept,
you're somehow
combining these criteria
into a single measure,
whether you're doing
that explicitly or not.
So how do you deal with
these multiple criteria?
We'll talk about that.
Here's the point
that you brought up.
What if there's ties?
How do you break them?
Group decision making versus
individual decision making--
who gets to really
make the decision?
Right?
And this relates to the
stakeholder analysis.
Who has the power to make
the decision in the end?
And then uncertainty-- did
we choose the right criteria?
Did we evaluate each
option properly?
And then the big one
is are the the best
alternatives represented?
So you can choose
among A, B, and C,
but maybe there's this much,
much better architecture
concept D out there, but
it's not in the decision set.
Because it didn't--
nobody thought of it,
or some other thing happened,
and it didn't come up
in concept generation.
Right?
So there's a lot
of uncertainties
when you're doing this.
So you have to be aware of it.
So let me talk about two--
again, quote, end
quote-- "simple methods"
for doing concept selection.
The first one is
called Pugh matrix,
and then I'll talk
about utility analysis.
So the Pugh matrix, essentially,
is a very discrete method.
It uses essentially plus, zero,
and minus to score alternatives
relative to a datum.
A datum is a reference decision,
a reference architecture.
And this is named
after Stuart Pugh,
who is a British professor
of design, essentially.
And it's a very simple method.
And it's used extensively.
It does have some pitfalls, as
well, but it's very well known.
So Pugh matrix
And then the second one is
called utility analysis.
So it essentially
maps all the criteria
to a dimensionless utility,
this is between zero and one.
So zero is a completely
useless system.
It has zero utility.
And one is a system that
has perfect utility.
It can't really be improved.
You could try to improve
it but your satisfaction
would not increase, OK?
And this has very deep
mathematical theory,
particularly the Von
Neumann and Morgenstern
utility that was
basically developed
in the mid-twentieth century.
Anybody seen the movie
A Beautiful Mind?
Yeah?
What is is A
Beautiful Mind about?
AUDIENCE: It's about John--
mathematician John Nash who's
a mathematician who won--
I forget exactly what
prize he had won.
PROFESSOR: He won
the Nobel Prize.
AUDIENCE: Was it
the Nobel Prize?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Founded game theory.
PROFESSOR: For what?
For game theory, right.
And so one of
Nash's contributions
was the idea of a
Nash equilibrium.
So we have multiple
decision makers in gaming,
and the question is--
you have your current
strategy, but is there
a better move you could make?
And if you could make
a better move that
improves your satisfaction,
or your utility,
but by doing this, you decrease
somebody else's utility,
you may not go there.
So if you reach a
Nash equilibrium,
that means that everybody
believes that this
is the best they can achieve.
And how do you measure that?
Well Nash actually developed
his Nash equilibrium and game
theory building upon theories
of Von Neumann and Morgenstern.
So there's a very
deep theory behind it.
I'm not going to go
very deep into it,
but so you know that there's
a lot behind utility analysis.
OK, so let me just talk
you through the basic steps
for doing a Pugh
matrix analysis.
And I'll show you a
very simple example.
First step, you choose
or develop the criteria
for comparison.
So, what's important?
How are we going to decide this?
Selection.
And obviously this
should be based
on a set of system
requirements and goals.
Now, there are two
flavors of requirements.
Remember, what-- let's
ask here at EPFL.
You remember the two
flavors of requirements?
What were the two
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I mean, there's
actually six types, right?
There's functional requirements.
There is constraints.
There's interface
requirements, and so forth.
What I'm trying to get at
is there are requirements
that use shall
statements and then
there's requirements that
use should statements, right?
So the shall
statements are what?
What do the shell
statements imply?
AUDIENCE: So basically, for
the shall, it's compulsory,
and for should, it's
a goal of the system.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Exactly.
So, in some sense,
the shall state--
the criteria associated
with shall statements
don't necessarily make the best
criteria for the Pugh matrix,
because by definition, the
concepts that you're evaluating
should all satisfy
the shall statements.
Because if they don't, they're
essentially infeasible, right?
And you shouldn't select
among them in the first place.
So architectures, or
concepts, or alternatives
that violate shall requirements
do not satisfy the must
have requirements.
And you shouldn't-- so you
shouldn't use criteria that are
associated with
hard constraints.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Now the requirements
that are associated with
should statements, those are
good criteria for this Pugh
matrix, because the degree
to which you satisfy this,
the goals are somewhat variable.
Therefore, you can then
compare amongst alternatives.
OK?
So that's number one.
Number two-- thank
you, that was good--
select the alternatives
to be compared.
So that those are coming out
of concept generation and one
little bit tricky aspect here
is when you're putting together
the alternatives, the
concepts to be selected from,
they should be represented
at a similar level
of detail of abstraction.
It is not good to have one
concept that's really detailed,
and you know a lot
about it, and often it's
kind of an existing system or
something you've done before,
and then there's this other
concept that is very fuzzy.
Why shouldn't you compare
something very detailed
with something very,
very poorly defined?
Why do you think that's
not a good practice?
What do you guys think here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it like--
it's not fair, because--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
It's a fairness issue,
and because the concepts
that are poorly
defined often, you're
too optimistic about them.
That's sort of the typical--
this looks really
good, very promising,
but it looks very
promising because it's
kind of ill-defined.
So that's important.
Try to represent
all the concepts
at about the same
level of detail
when you make the comparison.
That's number two.
Number three-- you actually
go through and generate
the scores.
And the key thing
here-- this is maybe
the most important thing
about the Pugh matrix
is you always use a datum.
The datum is a reference--
one of the alternatives
that you're going to
compare is your reference.
So what you do is you always
compare every other alternative
in the set against the datum,
and you say for each criterion
is it better?
Is it about the
same, or is it worse
than the reference, the datum?
So you don't compare
all the alternatives
pairwise against each other.
You always compare
against the datum.
Then you compute
the total scores
and I'll show you
this in the example,
and then there's
variations like--
rather than better,
equal, or worse,
you could go to a five-point.
Much better, a little
better, or about the same.
So there are some
variations on the scoring,
but the classic method just
uses better, the same, or worse.
So here's some--
AUDIENCE: Excuse
me, just a question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Just about
the number three,
about generic scores
and user datum--
by doing so, don't you exclude
a solution that could have,
under the generic picture,
be better then others?
PROFESSOR: What do you
mean by general picture?
AUDIENCE: You should take all
the solution that you have,
and at the end, one performs
slightly better than the other,
but you couldn't spot
it by using the datum?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it's a very good question.
And so this is a question
of resolution right?
How good is your resolution?
The main purpose
of the Pugh matrix
is not for making the
final choice right away.
The main purpose
of the Pugh matrix
is actually to eliminate
concepts that are--
you can tell already that
they're not competitive.
And you don't typically
do Pugh matrix one time
and then say that's
the best one.
You use it, essentially,
to eliminate
purely inferior solutions.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: I'm really sorry
but the video cut just
during your explanation.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
let me repeat this.
So the purpose of
the Pugh matrix
is not to select
the final concept
as a result of doing
the Pugh matrix,
but to identify
inferior concepts
to eliminate them from the set.
OK?
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So here's a kind
of generic example
to explain how this works.
So here's our Pugh matrix,
our evaluation matrix.
On the rows, we
have our criteria.
It could be cost, performance,
resilience, effectiveness,
and so those are called
A, B, C, D, E, and F.
So we have six criteria.
And then the column--
each column
represents a concept,
a design, an architecture.
And so you know
we're designing--
I guess we're designing
beams here, or levers,
or something like that.
So this is a solid cylinder.
This is a cylinder
that's hollow.
This is a square,
it's cross-sectioned.
This is a triangular
cross-section.
You get the picture, right?
There they're
qualitatively different.
And then you note which one
is our is our reference here?
Which concept?
Number seven, right?
If you look at seven this
sort of shallow triangle.
Seven, it says datum.
You see that?
Which means that
this is our baseline,
our reference, our datum.
And then what you do is,
as you fill this in--
and you can do it two ways.
You can do-- pick, say, concept
one, the solid cylinder,
and then compare it against
seven for all criteria.
So A, so concept one is better
than concept seven in criterion
A. So it gets a plus.
It's also better in
B. It gets a plus.
It's worse in C and D, so this
is a minus compared to seven,
and so forth.
So the two ways of
filling it in is
you do concept by
concept, column-wise,
or you can do it row- wise.
And there's some arguments
in favor of one or the other.
But essentially, you
fill in this matrix
by always comparing
against number seven.
Alexis, what's your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just a question.
Shouldn't we weight
the criteria?
I mean, for example, if the
criteria A is more important,
shall we put more weight on it?
PROFESSOR: No.
No.
At this point, in
the Pugh matrix,
the criteria are unweighted.
This is very important.
You don't say B is
twice as important as C.
They're unweighted
when you first do this.
Eventually, when you
do the final selection,
you will probably weigh them.
But when you first do
this, there's no weighting.
They're equal.
OK?
Yes?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Are there any
rules in picking your datum
or do you just pick arbitrarily?
PROFESSOR: So I'll
get into that.
It should be a design that
you think is competitive,
that [INAUDIBLE]
maybe you know it,
maybe it's an existing
sort of system,
there's data on it,
a known quantity.
But if you don't
have if you don't
have any information,
if they're all equal,
then it's a random choice.
OK?
So, then once you've
filled in this matrix--
so S here is for same, right?
About the same.
Then you essentially
sum all the pluses,
you sum all the
minuses, and then
you have the net
result, unweighted.
Right?
So, here you can
essentially compare
that, you can see that
concept one is better in three
and worse in three
than the datum.
You can see that concept
two is inferior in three
criteria, better in two,
and the same in one.
But we're not actually summing.
We're not actually
summing at this point,
because we're not
weighting these, OK?
But it gives you a
basis of understanding.
OK so let's do a quick
partner exercise.
What do you see as
the main advantages
and potential disadvantages
or pitfalls of this method?
So turn to your partner,
discuss this for a few minutes,
and then we'll see
what you came up with.
[MICROPHONE NOISE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right.
Good.
So let's see advantages.
Let's get a couple
here, and then we'll
sort of go back and forth
between here and EPFL.
So what are-- what's
good about this method?
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So, Nate
and I were talking
that it is a relatively simple
decision making process.
So instead of just going with
some sort of gut feeling,
or not looking at everything,
you can get stuff down on paper
and actually see
these criteria and how
they relate to each other.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So simplicity.
What else?
Go ahead, Sam.
AUDIENCE: It allows you to look
at a large array of concepts
very quickly.
PROFESSOR: OK large samples.
Sorry.
Quick, right?
You said quick.
.
OK.
What advantages, EPFL, what
did you guys come up with?
So simple, it allows us to
look at a lot of concepts.
It's quick.
What else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] we got
[INAUDIBLE] the same things.
This method is simple, and
it's pretty fast and pretty
straightforward, too.
So this is a good way to get
rid of some of the concepts
pretty fast.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Anything else that we
didn't [INAUDIBLE]??
There's one more that I would
like to put on this list.
Veronica, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Qualitative.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I kind of
like [INAUDIBLE] improvements,
rather than this is better
because the requirement is--
AUDIENCE: Please put
on the microphone.
PROFESSOR: I think-- can you
just quickly repeat that?
AUDIENCE: Just that
it's qualitative.
PROFESSOR: And that you see
that as an advantage, actually.
AUDIENCE: I think you
can see it both ways.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I think what you implied
with is it stimulates
the discussion, right?
Stimulates debate.
AUDIENCE: There may be another
criterion on the positive side.
PROFESSOR: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: And it would be that
it's extremely easy to explain
to [INAUDIBLE],, to [INAUDIBLE],,
to whoever your customer is,
because-- and they
can relate to it.
If the criteria are mostly
physical or scientific, I mean,
larger, stronger,
lighter, cheaper,
it's probably very
intuitive, yes, as I say.
PROFESSOR: OK, great.
Now, downsides.
What are the downsides
of the method?
Go ahead.
Make sure you--
AUDIENCE: I think it
definitely depends
on which you pick as a datum.
Like, if you pick the clearly
best one as the datum,
then it's not going to
give you much information.
Or if you pick the worst one
as the datum, then all of them
will be better.
And you kind of don't
really gain much information
from that.
So you have to like iterate
with different datums.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
There's actually
research on this.
There's some research-- this
matrix, this Pugh matrix
method, by the way,
has been studied
scientifically quite a bit.
There's quite a
literature on it.
And the point that you
brought up was studied.
They would basically
give the same criteria
and the same alternatives to
different groups of people,
but then give them
a different datum.
And it's a little tricky--
is the result different
because it's a
different group dynamic?
Or is it-- but this has
been done statistically,
and the choice of datum has
an impact on the outcome.
Very good.
That's actually a
pretty subtle point.
That was excellent.
What are some other--
yes, please go ahead.
AUDIENCE: While it's
very easy to implement
and anyone can do it,
it is very subjective.
So if you have
somebody that doesn't
have a whole lot of
experience in a certain area,
they may get a completely
different answer
than somebody who
is an expert looking
at the same type of criteria.
PROFESSOR: Subjectivity-- which
basically, repeatability--
may be low, right?
You want to have robustness
of the methods such
that if you repeated
this multiple times
or you gave it to
different groups of people,
you want to have some confidence
that the results will come up
similarly.
Very good.
Let's see at EPFL,
any downsides?
So datum dependent, subjective--
what else?
AUDIENCE: So what
we are thinking
is that the criteria
depend, from group to group.
It doesn't seem to be clearly
defined what you need.
Although, there are some
that are straightforward
and our other point--
AUDIENCE: Datum dependence?
That's what we--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
datum dependence.
If it was a very easy solution,
or if a very bad solution
as a reference, then all
the others look good.
And finally, if you have a--
if you judge on the
overall concept,
and maybe you discard
one or two solutions,
but inside those
concepts you have ideas
that you could keep or use,
then they might be lost.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
loss of sub-concepts.
OK.
Good.
Anything else here?
Mike.
AUDIENCE: We were talking
about how it's very easy
to tune your metrics to be--
like to be biased.
PROFESSOR: I see.
Such gaming, right?
Gaming-- gaming the--
basically producing a matrix to
give you the answer you want,
that you already had
preordained, sort of.
Right?
That essentially
what you're saying.
.
OK.
Very good.
So these are all--
go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Just sort of
one last disadvantage
of the method that I think
is a bit interesting,
because I think the way
of grading everything with
plus or minus can be
[INAUDIBLE],, because you can
imagine a system, for instance,
that is very, very good in one
criteria, and then pretty
bad in all the others,
and it could be a
good concept that
is disregarded nonetheless.
PROFESSOR: What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Bastian.
PROFESSOR: Pasqual?
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: Pasqual.
Is your name Pasqual?
AUDIENCE: Bastian.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Keep that point
until-- we're going
to talk about exactly that point
when it comes to non-dominance,
OK?
So please reserve--
this is great.
Just, we'll come back to
that in a few minutes, OK?
All right, so this is great.
I think you really got it.
This is exact-- this
is a very good list.
So, you may say well, OK
this is good for beams
and you know very simple things.
So, I want to show
you an example
of an application of the Pugh
matrix to what I would argue
is a fairly complex
architectural decision.
And what I'll talk to
you about is a thesis
that was done here at MIT
in 2003, so a while ago,
12 years ago, by Brian Smith.
He was an STM student, and was
one of the easiest students
ever to advise.
Very knowledgeable in nuclear
propulsion and nuclear power.
He's now the branch chief
for nuclear power propulsion
at NASA Glenn research
center in Ohio.
And so, at the time,
NASA had a mission
that was kind of high
priority called JIMO--
Jupiter icy moons mission.
And when you go out
to Jupiter, and you
want to not just do a
fly by but you actually
want to go to
different orbits, you
want to do high power imaging,
you need a lot of power.
You're far from the sun.
RTG's only give you 100
watts or so, per RTG.
So nuclear power is
pretty much the way to go.
But there's a lot
of different choices
of different nuclear
reactor architectures
that would potentially--
and then couple that with
the propulsion system.
So that was the challenge was
sifting through the large space
of possibility for
nuclear electric power,
nuclear exploration class
electric power and propulsion
systems.
And you know, here's the
way the study was set up
is the expansion phase,
the filtering, and then
the screening phase.
So here's the architectural
space the way it was defined.
So nuclear electric power and
propulsion is what we're after.
And there's different ways to
generate these alternatives.
So the most important
is the design vector,
the type of reactor, the
operating temperature,
the power conversion scheme,
the heat exchange, and then
the fuel type.
And then there
were requirements.
So this is the power range,
the delivery timeline,
the fact that you should be able
to do it in a single launch,
and then the operational
lifetime of the system.
So those are the
shall requirements.
Every architecture had to meet
these requirements otherwise
it would not be considered.
And then there were some things
that were assumed as constants.
They're shown here.
There was a policy
vector in terms
of funding profiles,
international partnerships,
at what altitude you could
insert the system into orbit,
and then influence
on future missions.
And the objective vector is
the criteria for the decision.
Technology-- TRL is
Technology Readiness Level.
How much infrastructure
do you need?
Complexity.
Strategic value to the nation.
This is a little fuzzy, but
basically what this means is,
could you use it for
other applications
than exploring Jupiter?
The schedule.
The launch packaging.
Power.
Specific mass, which
is watts per kilogram.
The lifetime.
So it's interesting you
have lifetime here and here.
So there's a minimum lifetime,
right, and if you satisfy this,
the extra life you
get can actually
be used as a decision criteria.
How does it interact
with the payload?
Do you need a lot of shielding?
And then adaptability?
Can you adapt it for
different missions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In the previous
slide, it listed both possible--
on the previous slide, we had
both possible and feasible
on there as different
kind of criteria.
What do you have for a
difference for those?
PROFESSOR: So essentially,
possible is, this
is sort of the
combinatorial space.
And then, applying
the hard constraints
based on the requirements
vector gets you
from possible to feasible.
They satisfy your must
have requirements,
your shall requirements,
and then you
use, in screening, you
use the objective vector--
these criteria-- you use
to go from here to here.
So let me show you
what this looks like,
and I'll post this thesis,
if you're interested.
It's really-- the whole thesis
is about doing this process.
So here we have--
each column represents a
different reactor architecture.
So you can see in the legend
what these things mean.
So for the reactor type, we
have a liquid metal, gas cooled,
or heat pipe type reactor.
These are three types of
nuclear fission reactors.
For fuel, we have two types of
fuel, if I remember correctly.
We have UO2 or UN.
For the temperature at which
the reactor would be run,
we have medium or high.
For the conversion-- this
is the thermodynamics.
How do you get the heat
out of the reactor?
We have a Brayton
or a Rankine cycle,
or a thermoelectric
reactor, which is basically
directly converting
the heat to electricity
without a working fluid.
And then, D is the heat
exchange architecture, which
is either direct or indirect.
And so you can see that
each of these columns
represents a different
kind of architecture,
and they're colored here by--
the dark is a direct heat pipe
with liquid metal reactor,
and so forth.
So that's essentially--
what you're seeing here
is the filtered set that
is deemed to be feasible.
Potentially feasible.
And then the actual screening
is done based on this.
So this is the actual
Pugh matrix here.
So we have the
concept combinations,
which are the columns.
The datum here is the one
that's shaded in gray.
So it's a liquid metal
reactor with a thermal--
it's a liquid metal
thermoelectric reactor
with indirect heat exchange, UN
fuel type and a high operating
temperature.
And why was this chosen?
Well if you look here,
it says SP100 reference.
So the US actually has
launched-- at least,
officially, as far as we know--
one nuclear reactor into
space, and that's the SP100.
You can look it up.
There's a history behind it.
And that's the
architecture of the SP100.
So it was launched.
We had data on it.
It's a known quantity.
The Russians, it turns out--
Russia has launched a
lot of nuclear reactors
over the years.
But this is sort
of the US baseline,
if you want to call it that.
And then all of these
other combinations
are compared against the
SP100, the reference reactor.
And so, you can see here that
the comparison is drawn again.
So zero means it's about--
so for TRL, it means it's
about equally mature.
A plus means it's
actually more mature.
A negative means it's less
mature than the SP100.
And at the end of
this, you can actually
look at the total pluses
and zeros and minuses,
and then in this
case, what Brian did,
he did calculate a net score.
That's an unweighted score.
Basically, if you give
one point-- so let's
look at the first one.
So it has four pluses, right?
It has four pluses, and it
has five equal to the SP100,
to the datum, and has two minus.
So it's worse than two,
better in four criteria,
and the same in five.
So the net score
would be plus two,
because it's better
in two criteria, net.
But it's unweighted.
And so in order to
figure out what--
based on this net score,
so a zero net score
would say it's about
equal to the datum,
but it maybe in other,
different criteria.
But essentially
it's about the same.
If it's a plus two, then
it is potentially better
than the SP100.
But you don't know
that 100%, because you
haven't weighted the criteria.
It's really used for screening.
So the ones that are circled
are better, essentially,
than the datum.
And the ones that are--
this is-- I'm sorry, the rank.
This is the rank among the set.
So if you have a one here,
you're in the rank one.
And there's two architectures,
the first two are rank one.
And then we have
this architecture,
which is ranked two.
The datum itself, plus two other
architectures, are rank three.
And then you see
that there's some--
like, for example,
this architecture here
is rank eight, right?
So it-- why is that?
Because it's not better in
any criteria than the datum.
It's the same in six.
And it's worse in five, right?
So that gives you an indication
that this particular concept
probably is not very attractive,
and you would eliminate that.
OK?
So that's essentially an
application of the Pugh matrix
to a pretty real-world,
complex problem.
So what the Pugh matrix is for
is essentially structured--
structuring and representing
the evaluation procedure.
It serves as a common visual.
It provides some
amount of discipline,
and helps break down
self-sealing behavior,
meaning--
what that means is people
defending their concepts
without sort of seeing
the bigger picture.
Encourages teamwork.
It helps you eliminate
weaker ideas,
retain a set of
stronger concepts.
And then this is
interesting-- divergence.
It helps to identify
opportunities for combination.
There's also a way to
use this Pugh matrix
methods multiple times.
And the way you
would do this is you
would say, OK so these are the
stronger concepts here, right?
The ones that do equally
well or maybe even
a little better than the datum.
What are the strengths and
weaknesses of each concept
and can we hybridize them?
Can we create some
hybrid concepts?
And so you eliminate
the weaker ones.
The surviving concepts are
kept, and then maybe hybridized
with each other.
So you expand and create
more concepts again.
Maybe a little
bit more detailed.
And then you apply
the Pugh matrix again.
So it's iterative application
of the Pugh matrix, where
you eliminate, you keep strong
concepts, you hybridize them,
and then you repeat
it two or three times.
And there's actually
research on this, as well.
Professor Dan Frye,
who is here at MIT
in mechanical engineering,
has done research on that
and shown that that can actually
lead to very good outcomes.
So this sort of gradual--
so then, you don't have just
one expansion and contraction
of your concept space, but it
sort of goes multiple times.
But eventually it does converge.
So this is a more refined
application of the method.
What Pugh matrix is not good for
is automatic decision-making,
right?
Completely controlling
the process.
So, you know, the idea of
automating the Pugh matrix--
it should not be automatic.
And it's not really
done-- it's not
really good for trade studies.
Challenges-- [LAUGHS]
so here's some quotes.
"People who have a
lot of experience
exhibit an impatience.
Get on with it.
This procedure holds us back."
Right?
"Strong-willed individuals
who have a lot of experience
and whose initial concepts
have not emerged in the final
selection commence a defense
based on emotion, experience,
and bluster."
Right?
So there's this social dynamics
that gets unfolded here.
So, therefore, it is
recommended to do Pugh matrix
with a facilitator.
Somebody who-- similar
to brainstorming, right,
where you have a facilitator.
So you have a facilitator
for Pugh matrix.
So somebody who controls
the flow and pace
of the session,
records the results,
tries to maintain
some discipline.
Always compare
against the datum.
I've seen Pugh matrix sessions
where you start with the datum,
and then by the third
or fourth concept,
people are starting to
do pairwise comparisons,
and the datum is sort of lost.
That should not happen, right?
Preventing tangents, but
encourage clarification.
What do we really
mean by criteria?
Clarification of the concepts,
and then opportunities
for divergence in hybrids.
So the critique
of the method is--
I think a lot of these things
you've already mentioned.
The ranking depends on
the choice of datum.
The weighting.
You know, there's
no real weighting
in the classic method.
However, you can implement a
weighted version of the Pugh
method, but then you have
to have the whole discussion
about the weightings, a priori.
Next, I'm going to talk about
multi-attribute utility.
And so Pugh matrix and
multi-attribute utility
could give you a different
rank order of alternatives.
So how do you reconcile that?
The most important criteria
may be intangible and missing
from the list.
And my personal opinion on
this is that the Pugh matrix
is useful and simple to use.
It stimulates discussion about
the criteria, the alternatives,
but it shouldn't be your only
means of concept selection.
But it's usually one
of the first things
you should do because you
learn a lot from doing it.
OK?
Any questions about
matrix before I move on?
Yes, Sam?
AUDIENCE: Should
it always be done
with a group that's working
together and discussing
the concepts?
Or could you also have
people individually
filling them out and then
combining their results?
PROFESSOR: So yeah, usually
you do it as a group
because in the discussion
with the group,
there's a lot of
clarification that happens.
Now if you do it separately,
and you firewall people
from each other and have people
do this individually and then
try to combine the results
later, that's actually called--
that's closer to a method
called the Delphi method.
Which I'm not going
to talk about here.
But the Delphi
method means you're
asking these kinds of
questions to experts.
They give you the answers, and
then you anonymize the answers
and reflect the combined
answers back to the group.
And then you eliminate
the social dynamics,
and you can see whether was
my assessment an outlier,
am I close to the
center of the group?
So the Delphi method
has a lot of benefits,
but it's not usually--
you don't have
the social dynamic
in the same way, which is sort
of essential to make this work.
Good question though.
Any questions at EPFL about
Pugh matrix before I move on?
AUDIENCE: No, it's clear.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It is useful to almost
have an independent group do
this, as opposed to everyone
generates their ideas
and then everyone's trying
to fill out the matrix so
that their idea wins.
PROFESSOR: Usually not,
because if you give it
to an independent
group, they'd know
much less about the problem.
They probably weren't involved
in generating the alternatives,
they weren't involved in
selecting the criteria.
They're probably not
as knowledgeable.
And so there is an advantage
of doing it within the team.
But then, you know, before
you actually go and pull
the trigger on the
final-- that's the PDR.
You get vetted by
independent people.
That's what happens at the PDR.
OK.
AUDIENCE: One point here is that
you can invite external people
to join your discussion.
So you have your design team.
And it's very good to
have the experts to come,
sit in the meeting, and
then give their opinion,
and with the Pugh
matrix, as it's
pretty straightforward
and simple,
you probably shouldn't
then bias the result,
but you could
probably enrich it.
PROFESSOR: That's a great point.
I agree with that, [INAUDIBLE].
Absolutely.
Yeah.
OK.
So let's switch gears
to utility theory
or multi-attribute
utility theory.
So what's that all about?
So like I said, utility is
a very deeply rooted concept
in economics.
And so it's defined
as, "Utility is
a measure of relative
happiness, or satisfaction,
or gratification gained by
consuming different bundles
of goods and services."
This is sort of
economic-- very--
this is how economists talk.
So it's-- the idea is you
want to choose a concept
or alternative that will
maximize your happiness,
your satisfaction,
your gratification.
And whenever you buy something,
when you go to Anna's Taqueria,
or wherever you guys have
lunch, or at EPFL you
go to the Rowlock center,
and you pick from the menu,
you're actually doing
just that, right?
You have-- how much money
do I have in my pocket?
How hungry am I?
Am I a vegetarian or not?
That would filter out some
menu items right away, right?
And you pick, every day.
You pick your lunch.
Well, you're doing exactly this.
You don't really know
that you're doing it,
but in your mind, as you're
picking from the menu,
and then making
your choice, you're
maximizing your
utility at that moment.
So we do this every day.
Here, in this class,
we talk about designing
complex systems.
So we need to do it a little
bit more deliberately,
but this is not just
some abstract thing.
We do this every day.
And so the idea is, essentially,
we have this Consumption Set
X, which are our
alternatives-- mutually
exclusive alternatives--
and then we
map that to the real scale.
We rank each member of
the Consumption Set.
So we map the alternatives
on this utility scale.
In this case, the cardinal
scale between zero and one.
So, the way this
is done, in order
to do the mapping from
the criteria to utility,
you need these
mapping functions.
And we call these
utility functions.
They're called
So basically we have--
I'm going to use J here for--
J means, essentially, your
attribute, your objective.
And then U is your utility.
And so there are different
shapes of utility functions.
And different scholars
call them differently.
So this is Cook.
He says, this is smaller is
better, or larger is better.
And you see they're essentially
monotonically increasing
or decreasing curves.
Messac, another scholar
in multi objective design,
calls this class 1S, class 2S.
So what would be an
example of a smaller
is better utility function?
What would be an
example of that?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: An example would be
the weight of a launch vehicle.
It's decreasing.
PROFESSOR: The launch mass?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Launch mass.
OK.
What about EPFL?
Smaller is better.
AUDIENCE: Cost.
PROFESSOR: Cost, right.
So, larger is better?
AUDIENCE: Revenue.
PROFESSOR: Revenue.
Maybe range, endurance,
reliability, right?
Then there's-- the next one is
strictly concave or strictly
convex, which is
nominal is better.
So the idea there is
there's a sweet spot, right?
You want the performance
or the attribute
to be a pretty specific
value, and if you
deviate from that on
the up or down side then
the utility decreases.
So what would be
an example of that?
AUDIENCE: Size of a meal.
PROFESSOR: Size of a meal, OK?
Well, some restaurants
may beg to differ, right?
All you can eat.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what their objective is.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
All right.
Very good.
Yes, Sam?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
has to interface
with something else
[INAUDIBLE] you're not
[INAUDIBLE] it [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yup, so if there
is a very specific interface
condition.
Yeah.
OK, go ahead at EPFL.
Nominal is better.
AUDIENCE: Like, for example,
ambient temperature.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So temperature-- ambient
temperature, right?
Humans are pretty-- we have
a fairly narrow range where
we say, this is good.
Now we can put on a sweater or--
but it's a fairly narrow range.
So, great example.
Then the next one
is range is better,
which is concave or convex.
So this is the idea that as long
as you're within this interval,
within the interval itself,
you're sort of indifferent.
Right?
But then when you drop
outside the interval,
then utility decreases
or increases.
And then the last one is very
exotic-- non-monotonic utility
functions that have
multiple peaks.
They exist in theory, but in
practice, you almost never
see them.
I can't give you a good
example of multi-modal one.
But in theory they do exist.
AUDIENCE: Well, there
is one, and it's clearly
the landing sites on a planet.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Because you have
the one injection trajectory,
and then you have the primary
sites of the primary elipse,
then the secondary.
And it's non-monotonic,
mostly [INAUDIBLE]..
It doesn't go up, it goes down.
So you have ideal.
Then you are out of it.
Then you would land on rocks.
And then you have the next
plateau, and maybe a third one,
on one pass by.
PROFESSOR: That's
an interesting--
that's an interesting comment.
I'm trying to figure out
what's the attribute-- what's
the engineering attribute
that goes with that?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's the
tolerance on the injection.
I know that, at JPL--
by the way, thanks for
organizing the [INAUDIBLE]----
they made this
presentation, also,
of the landing of the rovers.
And they have the
primary ellipse
where they try to land--
well, try-- it
depends on the entry.
And then they have secondary--
if they miss the entry,
then they have very bad option.
And then, maybe a
little bit later,
they maybe can land
on the next plateau,
or in the next crater,
which is useful.
So they have this non-monotonic,
but degrading, function.
The first time is best.
The second would still work.
But in between, there's
a part that doesn't go.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Got to think about that one.
But that's an
interesting-- that's
a pretty interesting example.
So, the main point here is that
in order to calculate utility,
you need a translation function
between the engineering
or financial attributes of
each alternative and utility.
If it's not-- if it
was directly that,
you'd just have a linear, right?
It would be a 45
degree line, right?
Or negative 45.
But typically the mapping
from your attribute values
to the utility is non-linear.
And that's what this says.
So then the challenge
is well, how do you
get these utility functions?
Where do they come from?
And the answer is you've
got to do interviews,
you have to survey people--
the decision-makers, the
stakeholders we talked about.
They're the ones who
have these utility
functions in their minds,
even if they're not--
So you've got to
make those explicit.
So here's an example.
You may have three different
customers for your system.
User attribute, some
performance attribute.
Customer one is shown here.
They need a minimum
amount of performance,
but once you reach this
threshold, after that there's
no more utility.
But then customer two and
customer three are different.
They want-- their utility
increases gradually,
and in fact, customer three
doesn't see any much utility
until you hit this
much higher level.
So one of the challenges, then,
in designing these utility
functions when you have multiple
customers is to solicit this--
and there's interview and survey
techniques for doing that--
and then combining those.
And then the other
challenge in combining
them is that, remember
at the system level,
utility is still between
zero and one, right?
So if you had, for
example, two attributes,
and they both give
you perfect utility,
and you add them together
you'd get a utility of what?
You have two attributes.
Two.
But that can't be because the
total system utility can never
be better than one.
So you have to normalize.
As you combine
the utilities, you
have to normalize them, and
actually weight them as well.
So here's the equation when
you have two utilities.
You basically have the utility
of the system just from J1--
your first attribute--
times the utility of J2.
This is the mixed term,
right, the combined term.
Plus the utility of just J1
plus the utility of just J2.
Then you have this K factor
here-- this capital K factor--
which re-normalizes
everything to zero and one.
And if you have
more than two, then
it becomes a matrix calculation.
So it's a little tricky for
how to do this properly,
but it's well-known
how to do this.
So the steps in multi-attribute
utility analysis
are to identify your
objectives and attributes,
you develop an
interview questionnaire,
you administer
that questionnaire.
You then develop your
aggregate utility functions,
you determine the utility
of your alternatives,
and then you
analyze the results.
And there is one word of
caution I want to give you,
which is that utility
is essentially
the surrogate of value,
but value often we
express in dollars,
in monetary terms.
But utility is unit-less.
So let me just comment
about utility maximization.
It's very common and
generally well accepted.
It's a non-linear combination
of your criteria-- your decision
criteria.
The downside of it is
the physical meaning
is often lost, because the
engineering or customer focused
attributes all get combined.
So you say this system
has a utility 0.83,
and this one has a utility 0.75.
So one is better than the
other, but immediately you
want to say well why is that?
What does that mean?
So then you have to backtrack
and reverse engineer
how those utilities
were calculated.
You need to obtain a
mathematical representation
for all utility functions, and--
this is a probably not
just US-M centric comment,
this is probably everywhere
in the world more or less--
but the utility function can
vary drastically depending
on the decision maker.
This is a big issue in
government programs.
So you guys, it's uniform
day, I guess, today.
So how long is a
typical tour of duty
of a program manager in the
Pentagon for a big program?
What would you say?
AUDIENCE: It's usually
three to four years.
PROFESSOR: So three to four
years, like it's written here.
And what does that that mean
in practice for these utility
functions and for programs?
Sorry I'm putting
you on the spot here.
AUDIENCE: Well,
you don't usually
have a lot of overlap
between the PM.
So, as one goes
out, another one's
coming in, so you're
losing a lot of experience,
gaining somebody who doesn't
have much experience.
So there's a
learning curve here.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's right.
What I'm getting at is--
so there's definitely that
effect--
but the priorities
may be different.
You know, whereas the prior
program manager really valued
a lot performance
or quick response,
and the next program manager--
because maybe the context has
changed--
is very, very cost conscious.
Really wants a system that
is very, very affordable,
and is willing to sacrifice
performance for that.
So the way you can think of
this is the shape of the utility
curves for those decision
makers has now shifted,
and because of that
the architecture
or the choice of concept
that you would go for
may be different.
AUDIENCE: This happens to
NASA all the time, right?
PROFESSOR: Right.
And so this is not
just a DOD issue.
And in commercial world.
You know, a new CEO comes
in, new CTO comes in,
and these utility
curves actually shift.
So you've got to be
to be aware of this.
So one of the big
topics there is--
particularly now with NASA is--
how do you choose an
architecture, a concept,
that is robust to changing
utilities and decision makers.
So maybe you don't go
for the super duper
best, most exciting,
most capable
concept, but you go
for the one that's
least likely to be
overturned or disrupted
with the next administration.
And this is a discussion--
active discussion--
right now at NASA headquarters.
You know, what are
the investments
you can make that are
going to provide utility,
even if the utility function
of the future decision makers
changes?
It's a big, big topic.
The other thing
is, of course, this
requires your formulation
of preferences.
Those K factors,
those weightings,
a priori-- before
you've actually
scored the alternatives.
All right.
So the example I want
to talk you through
is essentially a space tug.
So we're going to do
trade space exploration.
There's a trade space, a
design space, of alternatives--
conceptual alternatives.
And we're going to
try to understand
that using utility theory.
And let me explain to you
what we mean by space tug.
So a space tug is essentially a
satellite that has the ability
to change its orbital elements--
there are six orbital elements,
semi-major axis,
eccentricity, inclination,
right ascension of the
ascending node, and so forth--
of a target satellite
by a predefined amount
without degrading its
functionality in the process.
So here's a picture
of the earth.
There's two orbits.
The space tug is here
in the black orbit,
and then our target satellite
is in the orange orbit.
And so the typical
process is the space tug
waits in its parking
orbit-- the black orbit.
It gets tasked.
It transfers to the other
orbit, searches for the target,
identifies it rendezvous and
approach, docking and capture,
does an orbital transfer
and then releases the target
satellite at the new
orbit, verifies its status
and then either goes
directly to the next target,
or returns to the parking orbit.
And as you can
imagine, depending
on the plane changes
that are required here
this can be quite expensive.
It's less expensive in
geosynchronous orbit,
and there are some
capabilities that we
think heard about in
the public that US
and maybe other countries
have as well to do this.
But there's also applications--
commercial applications for it.
So, for example,
for space debris
removal and things like that.
So that's what we
mean by space tug.
So what are the attributes?
What are the-- so this is
based on a paper from 2003
called Understanding the Orbital
Transfer Vehicle Trade Space.
And so here's three attributes
that are combined into utility:
total delta V capability-- delta
V is the change in velocity.
This essentially tells
you where can it go?
You calculate that from
essentially the rocket
equation.
The second one is response time.
How fast can it get there
after it has been tasked?
And there there's a big
distinction between--
it's almost binary--
between electric propulsion,
which is very efficient
but slow, and then chemical
propulsion.
The third is the mass of
the observation or grappling
equipment.
And so this tells you what
it can do when it gets there.
So the size of target
satellites that can be actually
interacted with.
Those are the three attributes
that define utility,
and we combine those into a
utility between zero and one.
And then in this case, cost
or a surrogate for cost
is kept separately.
This is the vehicle
wet and dry mass.
These are the cost
drivers, and this
is calculated from some
simple scaling relationships.
And so what we're
interested in is
looking at the trade
space of utility
versus cost of the system.
So how is utility
defined for a space tug?
So we have response time, which
is bad in electric systems.
Total utility is a weighted sum,
and then we estimate the cost
from wet and dry mass.
So the delta V
utility is shown here.
This is in terms of
meters per second.
So two, four, six, eight,
10 kilometers per second.
These are pretty large delta
Vs. And what's interesting
is this is a larger is
better, but it's a step curve.
It's not a smooth curve,
it's a step curve.
Why is that?
Because as you reach
certain delta Vs,
it enables operating just in
GEO or a LEO-GEO transfer,
or a LEO-GEO return.
Right?
So you can use the space
tug more than once,
the more delta V you have.
And it's a step curve because as
you hit this value of delta V,
you can now operate
in a different regime.
The capability.
The payload mass
utility is essentially
discretized between low,
medium, high, and extreme.
So low is for small satellites.
Medium satellites up
to one metric ton,
up to three metric tons,
and then more than five
metric tons, which
are the big satellites
in geosynchronous orbit.
And then the weighting factors
are we're going to capability
30%, delta V 60%, and
the time responsiveness
of the system 10%.
So time responsiveness is
not that important compared
to the other two.
So once we have this--
I'm not going to go
through all the details
of the calculations.
That's in that paper,
which I'll post.
You get this.
So this is a cloud of points.
Each point here represents
a particular alternative
or architecture, and we have the
cost of the system in millions
of dollars.
So this is not cheap.
All right?
This is a billion dollars,
two billion, three billion.
And then we have this utility,
this dimensionless utility.
And, of course, what we're
particularly interested in
is this lower right corner:
high utility lower cost systems.
And what we did here is to
identify some particularly
interesting
architecture, as they're
shown here in this space.
So let me just
explain two of them.
One of them, here--
and we gave them names
that are recognizable.
So this point here,
it's below 0.4,
so it's a rather
lower utility system,
but it's also
relatively affordable.
We call it the bi-prop
low-earth orbit tender.
So it's intended for
use in low-earth orbit
and it has a dry mass
of about 680 kilograms,
a wet mass of 1,400.
So the difference
is propellant--
about 800 kilograms
of propellant--
and has reasonable
size and mass fraction.
And it's fairly responsive.
Another alternative is what we
call the electric geocruiser.
Sounds cool, doesn't it?
This is basically a space
tug that operates only
in geosynchronous orbit.
So you launch into
geosynchronous orbit,
but once it's there
it can do a lot.
But it's electric,
so it's kind of slow.
Seven hundred eleven
kilograms dry mass,
1,100 kilograms wet mass.
And it includes return of
the tug to a safe orbit.
And this is sort of a versatile
space tug in the GEO belt.
So that's the idea.
You calculate utility,
shown on the x-axis,
you have the cost of the system.
You have this cloud of points.
And you start
understanding what are
the interesting architectures
in that trade space.
This is the same trade space.
But now what we've
done here is we've
shown the choice of
propulsion system is critical.
And what you can see here,
it's really almost impossible
to get to a utility of one.
It's very, very hard.
And the reason for this
is the rocket equation.
You see how these--
so the blue are the
bi-propellant architectures.
The purple are the
cryogenic, so these are
[? lux ?] hydrogen propulsion.
The yellow ones are the
electric propulsion system,
and then we also have
nuclear propulsion, here,
which clearly is challenging
and has policy implications.
So you can see the
nuclear propulsion gets
you close to much
higher utility,
but it's also much,
much more expensive.
But in all cases,
as you're trying
to get more and more
utility, at some point
you hit the wall because
of the rocket equation,
which is very non-linear.
You know, more fuel--
in order to carry
more fuel, you need
more dry mass, more
fuel and dry mass
requires more fuel to push,
and the system blows up on you.
And you can see this
in these curves.
So you get some
physical intuition
in terms of the
shape of the space.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there a reason
between this layering of cost?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
They're essentially, if
I remember correctly,
the capability of the system.
Remember there's this
small, medium, large,
you know the size of
the grappling equipment?
I think that's the
tiering that you see.
AUDIENCE: That doesn't
change the utility?
PROFESSOR: Well, it depends
on the weighting, right?
So as you change the weighting
among the attributes,
that space can get scrambled.
This space is valid for
that particular weighting.
So any questions about--
this is utility theory,
multi-attribute utility theory,
applied to trade
space exploration.
Any questions?
Go ahead.
EPFL, do you have a question?
OK.
So now what you see
here is implicitly,
is there's nothing here
in the lower right corner.
There is no system that
has perfect utility
and is low cost.
Right?
There's an empty space.
We'd love to be here, but
there's nothing there.
So the best we can do
is get close to that.
And that's what I want to
talk about next, which is
this concept of non-dominance.
So what do we mean
by non-dominance?
What is a Pareto
frontier and what is
multi-objective optimization?
The key point about
this is that when
you do non-dominance
filtering, when
you look for Pareto
frontiers, you
do not need to express your
preferences ahead of time.
Right?
So when you do you a
weighted Pugh matrix or when
you do a utility theory, you
had to define ahead of time,
before you did the scoring,
what's more important--
fuel efficiency is twice
as important to me as cost.
Right?
The weighting, the
preferences had
to be expressed a priori--
before you did the scoring.
And there's arguments that
that's not the best thing
to do, but you can do it.
Here in non-dominance and
multi-objective optimization,
eventually you have to
express your preferences,
but you do it after
you've scored the options.
That's a really
important distinction.
So let me give you a little
history here on this.
And what's really interesting is
there's a Lausanne connection.
OK?
There's a connection
with Lausanne.
So the word Pareto
frontier is named
after a an economist,
who actually
started as an engineer,
Vilfredo Pareto.
He was born in Paris in
1848 and then graduated
from the University
of Turin in 1870.
Very much in engineering,
civil engineering,
his thesis title was The
Fundamental Principles
of Equilibrium and Solid Bodies.
Something we take--
that's pretty basic now.
Forces and torques in
equilibrium on a body.
Now he worked as a civil
engineer in Florence,
and then he got interested
in philosophy, politics,
and economics, and he started
to think about this in terms
of how does this concept of
equilibrium apply to economics?
And in 1893, he actually
became a professor
at the University
of Lausanne, which
is located right next
to EPFL, and started
applying this to economics
and societal theory.
And then he did-- some of his
work was a bit controversial,
but the one that I
want to talk about here
is this the idea of
the Pareto optimum.
And I will-- let me just
read this quote to you.
"The optimum allocation of
the resources of a society
is not attained,
so long as it is
possible to make at least
one individual better off
in his or her own estimation,
while keeping others
as well off as before in
their own estimation."
So what it means is if
you can make an investment
or make a change in society that
makes a particular individual
or group of individuals better
off in their own estimation,
without having to take the
resources from another group
and make them less
well-off, then you've
not reached an optimal
allocation of resources.
You know, if there
can be a win-win--
if everybody can be better off
by making certain investments,
you haven't yet found
the optimal strategy.
Only when-- the only way
to make somebody better off
in their own estimation than
somebody else is by taking--
and this is a big political
debate still today--
by taking from one group
and redistributing resources
to the other.
When you're in that
situation, then you
are at the Pareto optimal point.
OK?
So that's the key
idea underlying this.
So what this means
mathematically is that
an optimal solution --
X*-- is optimal if and only if--
for a feasible solution--
so, first of all the solution
has to be feasible.
And this is when you
have multiple criteria.
We're trying to do
vector optimization,
and x must be what we call
an efficient solution,
and it's efficient only
if its objective vector--
J of X-- is non- dominated.
And what this means is that
if you're looking at a point,
it's only efficient
when it is not
possible to move from that
point to another point
without degrading at least
one of the other objectives.
So if you can move from
a particular design point
to another design point, and
all the objectives get better,
you're not yet efficient.
You're not yet at a
Pareto optimal point.
And this gets us to the
notion of dominance.
So dominance-- let's say we have
two designs, two alternatives--
J1 and J2.
Those are their
objective vectors.
It means that-- this
is for maximization.
We're trying to maximize.
It means J1 dominates
J2 weakly if J1
is better or equal J2, and at
least in one of the objectives,
I, strictly better than J2.
So you could have
two alternatives.
This gets back to Pugh
matrix and the question--
who asked about the ties?
You did, right?
It's so long ago.
It's like, wait a minute, it's
like an hour ago, you know?
So we have two alternatives, OK?
They're all equal.
They're tied in all
criteria, except for one,
where J1 is better than J2.
Which means that J1 will
dominate J2, but weakly,
because there's some ties.
Right?
And then there's a
stronger definition,
which is that J1 strongly
dominates dominates J2 if
and only if it is
better strictly
better in all attributes.
So for J1 to
dominate J2 strongly,
it's got to be better in
all attributes than J2.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So I know this is
a bit abstract.
So let's do a concept
question that's
sort of based on a
hypothetical but real example.
So assume-- let's
say you're in charge
of designing in new
commercial aircraft,
and there's four criteria.
You want to maximize range.
You want to minimize the costs--
dollars per kilometer flown.
You want to maximize the
capacity of the airplane--
number of passengers.
And you want to maximize cruise
speed in kilometers per hour.
So it's a multi-objective
aircraft design.
You do all the work.
You do concept generation.
You come up with eight
concepts for airplanes,
and you evaluate them.
And they're shown here--
one, two, three, et cetera,
through eight.
So let's just look
at number one.
What does this mean?
Airplane number one,
concept number one,
has a range of 7,587 kilometers.
It has a operating cost
of $321 per kilometer.
It can carry 112 passengers.
And it has a cruise
speed or max speed
of 950 kilometers per hour.
So I'm going to leave this up.
This is like a five
minute-- this is--
on the next slide,
I'm going to ask you--
and we'll come back to this--
which of these airplane designs,
these eight, are non-dominated.
Meaning that they're not
dominated by any of the other.
And we're going to apply
weak dominance here.
That was going to be
your question, right?
Weak dominance.
So I don't think it
actually matters.
I don't think there's
too many ties in here,
but apply weak dominance.
So which of these
are non-dominated?
Meaning that you wouldn't
discard them right off the bat,
because there are some strong
features that they have.
So work through this.
You might want to write down
which ones are non-dominated.
And then we'll do
the concert question,
and then we'll show
you the answer.
AUDIENCE: I just
want to make sure.
So non-dominated as
in there is not one
that could be considered
better than it?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So, this is the definition.
All right.
So let me-- so please
submit your answers.
So here are the choices.
Which airplane designs
are non-dominated?
Five, six, and seven.
One, three, four, and eight.
One, two, three,
four, and eight.
Two, three, five, and six.
One, three, four, and seven.
Or you need-- this
is not answerable.
You need more information
to answer the question.
OK?
So we have a pretty
good distribution here.
So the wisdom of crowds
I think prevails.
So the correct answer is the
third one-- one, two, three,
four, and eight.
So 36% of you got it right.
Now let me let me show
you the solution to this.
So it is, in fact,
possible to answer this
without additional information.
So the way to do
this is you have
to do pairwise comparisons.
Now you said about--
I think your strategy--
What did you say, early on?
AUDIENCE: I was
looking at maximums.
PROFESSOR: You were
So you were saying
who's the best
performer among the
concepts for each criteria?
And you found those pretty
easily, I would assume, right?
So what--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you've got to
get the sign right.
Do you have the
mic on, by the way.
So what would--
if that concept is
the best performer
in a criterion,
what does that tell you?
AUDIENCE: It means that
none of the other performers
have something
equal to or greater
than that performer
for that criterion.
PROFESSOR: And this relates to
the question-- is it Martin?
Martin?
In the red shirt, first row?
I didn't get your name right.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Bastian.
PROFESSOR: Bastian.
Bastian.
You remember at the
start of the lecture,
you said-- what did you say
at the start of the lecture?
AUDIENCE: I said that if you
evaluate all the concepts based
on just plus or minus
for the criteria,
you might have one where
you evaluate all the--
a bunch of criteria
that are negatives,
but there's just one
that is positive.
But that one might be
very, very positive.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's exactly
the point here.
That's exactly this point.
If you are-- if this concept
is the best performer
in just one of the criteria.
Like it has the best
speed, or the lowest cost,
but it's terrible, terrible
in everything else,
it doesn't matter.
In terms of dominance,
it is non-dominated.
It cannot be dominated
by any other concept.
If you are the best in class,
even just for one criteria--
does that make sense?
You cannot be dominated by any
other design if you're the best
performer on just one criterion.
So let's think about
track and field.
So the people-- who's
doing track and field?
Any athletes here?
Like runners or javelin or--
Veronica.
I didn't know that about you.
Cross country and track.
OK.
So 5K?
All right.
So let's say--
I'm sure you were
very good at 5K.
And how was your shot putt?
AUDIENCE: I never
competed in the shot putt.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So then we don't know, right?
But the point I'm trying to make
is you could be a super duper
specialist in one criterion,
and that's-- you can will win
a gold medal with that.
But you're very maybe
not good in other things.
So that's the point
here is in order
to be dominated, if you're
the best performer--
so, right off the
bat, in this exercise
here, in our little
exercise, you
can remove all the concepts that
are best in class from the set.
Because they cannot
be dominated.
So they have to
be non-dominated.
OK, so the way
you do the scoring
with pairwise comparisons is you
say, let's compare one and two.
Concept one and two.
Well, one is better
in range, right?
And it's better in speed.
But then the second concept
is better in two and three.
So the score here
is two versus two,
which means neither one nor
two dominate each other, right?
Even if it's-- what
if it's three to one?
What if it was a
three to one score?
It would still be true, right?
That one doesn't--
one is, in a sense,
better because it's
better than the other.
But it doesn't dominate
it, because dominance
is a very crisp definition.
Now this is different, right?
Compare one versus number six.
Concept one versus concept six.
One is better in all
four criteria to six.
So clearly, solution one
dominates solution six,
and as a rational
decision maker,
you can eliminate
concept six from the set
because it is completely
dominated by concept one.
OK?
So in order to be
dominated, a solution
must have essentially a score of
zero in a pairwise comparison.
Now, if we apply this
to the full set of eight
we can actually show
this as a matrix.
I call that the
domination matrix.
It shows which
solutions dominate
which other solution--
the horizontal rows
and the vertical rows.
So the way you read this is
so where you see these dots,
these are dominance
relationships
in the pairwise comparison.
So this tells you that solution
two dominates solution five.
This tells us, if
we look column-wise,
solution seven is dominated
by solution two and solution
eight.
So, if we do the row sum-- if
we sum this along the rows,
the row indicates
how many solutions
this particular
solution dominates.
And-- but the question
was about non-dominance,
so we need to look
at the column sum.
The column sum
indicates by how many
other solutions the kth solution
or concept is dominated.
And when you do
this column sum, you
can see that concepts one, two,
three, and four have a zero.
They're not dominated
by any other design.
Column eight has a zero, and
concepts five, six, and seven
are dominated each by at
least one other concept, which
means that they're
dominated, and the others
are non dominated.
So when you do your
concept selection,
you can actually apply
this to a much bigger set.
Your filter out all the
dominated solutions.
And it turns out the bigger
your number of alternatives
or architectures, the smaller
percentage-wise the set
will be of
non-dominated solutions.
And those are the ones you
really want to focus on.
Is that clear?
I know this takes a
little thinking about,
what does this really mean?
But but that's a very
rigorous way to do it.
And then this gets
us to, eventually,
this gets us to the notion
of Pareto optimality.
So what's the relationship
between Pareto
optimality and non-dominance.
So let's say we have
two objectives, J1--
we want to maximize J1.
Maybe that's
performance, endurance.
We want to minimize J2--
maybe cost, for example.
So the Utopian point, or
the optimal corner to be in,
is the lower right.
We want to maximize
J1, minimize J2.
There's nothing here.
It's empty.
There's nothing feasible here.
So the best we can do
is get close to it.
So when you look at a
set of discrete points,
discrete concepts,
those concepts
can have three properties.
They can be D,
meaning dominated.
So all the red points
shown here are dominated.
And the way you can see
this if you draw a little--
let me try to let me
try to draw a box here.
Where's the eraser?
So let's pick a point,
a particular point--
Let's pick this
point right here.
Why do we know that
this point is dominated,
just looking at it graphically?
How do you know that?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The point
is not at the front.
PROFESSOR: It's
not at the front,
but the way the way
to find first of all,
whether it's dominated,
which is relative
to the other solutions, is we
can just draw a horizontal line
here, and a vertical line here.
And so in a
multi-dimensional space,
you're essentially
drawing a hyper-cube.
And down here is our utopia.
This is where we would love
to be, but we can't be.
It's not feasible.
And you see in this box, between
the point and the utopia,
there is this other guy here.
This point here.
And because it's there,
it's closer to the utopia,
and it dominates this
point in both objectives.
Let's take this point here.
Let's do the same thing.
Draw a vertical line
and a horizontal line.
And there's a whole
bunch of points,
all these points right
here are all the box,
closer to the Utopian point.
So this point here is actually
dominated by one, two, three,
four, five, six
seven other points.
So that's essentially dominated.
Let me erase this again.
Then we have these darker
red, purple points.
Let me just circle
them real quick.
So we have this point here, this
point, this point, this point,
this one, and this one.
And those are what we
call non-dominated,
like we just did the filtering,
meaning there there's
no other point in the set that's
better than it in all criteria.
So you would consider them
as concepts to choose from.
But they're not exactly
on that dashed line,
which means that there
is a way to improve them.
There's a way to tweak them,
to optimize them further,
if you could to get them
right onto that dashed line.
They're close but they're not
exactly on that dashed line.
So you could tweak these
concepts to get them
closer to the Pareto front.
But they're still pretty good,
because they're non-dominated.
And then we have those grey
points, which are shown here.
There's three of them.
Let me use a different
color for these.
color, maybe green.
Here.
This point, this point, and this
point, they are Pareto optimal.
Meaning they're on
the Pareto front.
There's no way to
improve them, such
that you could make
both objectives better.
Right?
If you want to make J1 better,
you have to sacrifice on J2.
So the only way to
modify these points
is to slide along
the Pareto front,
meaning you're trading
off the objectives.
Do you see that?
And so, in my spring
class that I teach,
called Multi-disciplinary
System Optimization,
we get into this pretty deeply.
Like how do you
actually do this?
But the point I want
you to keep for now
is that when you
select the concept,
do not select a dominated one.
Get rid of the dominated ones.
Filter them out.
And then you still have to
choose among the others,
and that's where your
preferences come in.
Right, so given the blue
and green choices here,
which one are you going
to recommend at the end?
And that this is sort of the
preferences between maximizing
J1 and minimizing J2.
That's a social
process of coming up
with your preferences.
But you now determine
those preferences
after you've scored
all the concepts.
Do you see the difference?
That's pretty fundamental.
OK.
So, one more thing and
then we'll wrap it up.
So now you've gone
through all this work.
You've done your concept
generation, concept selections,
scoring, and you
found the one concept
that you're going
to go forward with.
That's when you do PDR.
So what is the PDR?
The Preliminary Design Review.
You explain what concept and
system architecture was chosen.
You explain why it
was chosen, and you
want this to be approved
as the design baseline
for going forward and doing
more detailed design work.
You compare it against
the rejected alternatives.
Typically at the PDR, you will
spend some time on saying,
these are the other
interesting concepts
that almost were
selected, but we didn't
because of these reasons.
You show some quantitative
analysis that gives confidence,
especially you want to show that
the requirements that you had
defined and agreed
upon at the SRR
can be satisfied by
your chosen concept.
There's maybe still some
risk or some uncertainty.
So any risk reduction
experiments or prototypes.
So you can actually do
prototyping at this stage.
You don't want to
spend too much on that,
but you want to do enough of
it so you can reduce risks.
And then you do a preview
of the detailed design
phase between PDR leading
up to CDR. So here--
I'm not going to read this--
but this is the description
of what the PDR is all about.
In the NASA system engineering
handbook on page 177,
there's a very
detailed description
of entrance criteria, exit
criteria, et cetera, et cetera.
So here's a description from
a PDR from a European program,
and you can see it's a
pretty big group, right?
This is like 30, 40 people.
And because the PDR is
such an important decision,
that's when you also invite
external stakeholders.
And you want to make sure that
people come away from the PDR
with confidence that,
yeah, we have a good system
architecture.
We've picked the good
concept, and it's worthwhile
now putting all this
work into getting it
to a detailed design that
can actually be built.
OK.
Any questions about PDR, or
any experiences from PDRs
that people want to share?
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about the PDR.
So you said there's 30
people in that picture.
How do you reconcile that with
seven plus, minus two rule?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's seven,
plus or minus two, squared,
right?
So you have a
hierarchy of people.
Not everybody is a
decision maker here.
AUDIENCE: I see.
PROFESSOR: So you
probably have people
who did some of
the thermal design,
some people did
the cost modeling.
So, it's a great
question actually.
You want many, many
voices and people
who contributed to make
sure the PDR presents
all the information you have.
You don't want to do a PDR
with just seven people.
AUDIENCE: But I guess you could
say that in the presentation,
I guess, only seven plus
or minus two, will people
be driving at that
point in time.
PROFESSOR: So there will
be a leadership, right?
There is an
organizational issue.
But the point here is
that it's a big review.
It's a big milestone.
Please, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The big issue here is
that all the people who are not
decision makers, that
are in the picture, they
will have to implement
the detailed design,
so it's very important to
have them in the process.
Otherwise, you have to go back
to your organization and do
the PDR again to explain
the what's and the why's.
This is why you try to have
these very large meetings.
When you do a pre-PDR,
you do a dry-run,
and you send stuff in
advance and make sure
that you're really
all agreeing finally,
if possible, you get the
discrepancies off the table.
But then you all agree that
this is how to go forward
and then the worker
bees can go and do it.
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's another
reason for being inclusive.
I agree with that.
Any other-- who has gone through
a PDR in their prior work?
Anybody want to share?
Marissa.
Tell us about how that went.
I mean as much--
I know you can't probably
we share everything but--
AUDIENCE: For us, I mean, it
was a pretty big milestone.
You work a lot
leading up to a PDR
and then you finally have all
the really big stakeholders
in the room.
And a lot of them have been
involved during the design
phase, but when you actually
have them all sitting there.
And I think getting the
buy-in was also really--
I think that's a
really big part of PDR.
Like normally you're
feeling pretty
confident in your designs,
but then actually making
sure whoever the agency is
that you're working with,
then your stakeholders are also
kind of all on the same page.
It's pretty critical.
PROFESSOR: Did you discover
problems or discrepancies
during the PDR?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I definitely think-- just
generally we've had delta PDRs,
if things weren't
completely thought through.
Or you'd have a fair
number of action items
that come out of PDR
to go and address
before you really are allowed
to start moving towards CDR.
PROFESSOR: Good.
Any comments or experiences
with PDRs at EPFL?
AUDIENCE: I did a PDR
at the European Space
Agency during the
REXUS BEXUS program
three years ago, and
as far as I remember
it was very appreciated to bring
as many details as possible.
And to be very close to
that critical design review
stage in the PDR.
PROFESSOR: That's interesting.
So, that's good.
I think there's a good to
have detail and so forth.
But what's the downside?
Can you think of a
negative what would
be what would be not so good
about almost being a CDR right
there?
Can you think about
a downside to it?
AUDIENCE: Probably not
taking too much time
in order to clarify the
concept and the requirement
because you are in a rush
to finish the product.
PROFESSOR: That's a good point.
So it takes more time.
But what I'm thinking
about is it's
very difficult to then undo
the decision or backtrack.
Let's say that at the
PDR that there's some--
it could be that
you really forgot
something very important.
And that your concept
is actually flawed.
But you didn't know it as you
were working inside your team.
And then if you have a design
that's almost CDR quality,
it's very difficult
to undo that.
So I would say that a PDR--
I actually believe that at a
PDR you should have some detail,
but not too much yet.
I think a true PDR should be at
the system architectural level,
with some detail but
not all the details.
But thank you.
That's a great comment.
Thank you very much.
So let me close it here.
So in terms of concept selection
during conceptual design,
we can use Pugh
matrix selection.
And that's essentially
useful when we don't yet
have those detailed
mathematical models.
It's qualitative.
And then as we move more
into preliminary design,
we use utility analysis,
especially for noncommercial
systems where a net present
value-- a financial--
in commercial companies,
you will often
do a financial analysis
as a measure of utility.
And then this concept
of non-dominance
is very, very important.
Generating many designs
and then applying
Pareto filters to try to come
down to the non-dominated set.
So that's essentially
the essence of it.
So I hope that was clear.
A-4 will be posted later today.